Dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute nothingness
in the heart of the most holy Trinity. To give to my God the joy of fulfilling the purpose of my
existence by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother Mary and in
the divine will of God. And in this same manner may I live, pray, act, eat, walk, sleep and do
everything. May my soul be devoid of any other longings, wants or desires and may you my beloved
divine will do with me whatever you want or desire. All I ask is that you bind me to your most holy
will so intimately that I may never swear from carrying out what I know to be your good pleasure
and that I remain so docile to the movements of your divine will that you never perceive even a
breath of resistance in my soul to your requests of me. Come divine will with all the angels and saints
especially my sweet mother Mary to touch my forehead to imprint on it the Holy Spirit and infuse in
me true light so that I may understand the truths and the good that are in these writings and prayers.
Amen I want to begin with June the 15th 1926 and we're meeting the all and the nothing it's beautiful
text. Weza said I was feeling all full of defects especially because of the great repugnance I feel
when it comes to writing of the intimate things between myself and the Lord so she sees this huge
resistance within herself and she calls that badness or sinfulness the Lord's going to tell
her that's not so that's just her human reluctance. The weight I feel is so great that I don't know
what I would do in order not to do it in other words there's a huge struggle going on inside of her
and since the obedience of the one who is above me imposes itself though I would like to impose
myself now I love that human nature survives all attempts to transform it I think it's absolutely
brilliant and our will is intact we keep our will surrendered to the Lord but it is intact
he does not diminish it in any way so that even if you were in the divine will for 40 years the gift
that you give today is completely new is completely distinct and completely whole that is if you
really give so there's no such thing as just repeating for the sake of repeating and so here
Louisa has exactly the same reluctance to write what she is experiencing as she had at the very
beginning this has been going on for 19 volumes so in the next paragraph the nothing feels the
weight of the all is what Jesus is saying Louisa feels the weight and what Jesus does is he interprets
it so having gone through a similar struggle the text says contrast for some reason or other I felt
full of defects and totally bad that's because she's struggling as blessed Jesus came I told him
Jesus my life have pity on me look at how full of defects I am and how much badness there is in me
and he all goodness and tenderness said my daughter don't fear I am here I'm watching over you I'm
keeping your soul in custody now that's what he does for people really living in the divine will
he minds your soul and you probably don't need me to tell you that if you begin to deflect in any
way you're going to get quite and nudging from him not to do that not to go there so he said I'm
keeping your soul in custody so that not even the slightest sin may enter your soul now I want to
give you one John three versus two and six someone truly living in union with God does not sin but as
you can see here and as the saints all down the centuries have acknowledged that doesn't stop you
from having struggles and it's perfectly okay to struggle that doesn't stop you from having temptations
no temptation is a sin only giving into temptation is the same and also I would give you Sam 32 verse
two I think it is so what Louisa is calling badness and so on doesn't look like that in the Lord's
eyes it's like us saying to somebody well you know I feel awful today and they say to well you're
looking pretty good what other people see and what you see will be something different you're
looking at from completely different angles but in the case of the Lord he sees you internally as
well as externally so he's the one who knows the whole truth okay and Jesus said and where others
that means people who criticize you and you yourself find effects and badness I find none that is the
judge speaking he has looked he has found nothing now we've been through the journey that Louisa has
taken especially since volume 13 and how the Lord has been showing her that he was purifying her so
that she looked like crystal in his eyes now crystal means glass that the rays of the sun can come
through without any barrier whatsoever and they can come through fully okay so just because she's
struggling she thinks she's fallen back a bit and she says no you haven't what I see he said is that
you're nothing feels the weight of the all now we're going to go into that big time this evening
because we're going to be talking about who in fact we are actually dealing with and that this is a
universal response to God and therefore we have a massive responsibility and if it hits you at all
it's a weight so you're nothing feels the weight of the all in fact the more I elevate you intimately
to me and I make known to you what the all wants to do with your nothing that's when you feel you're
nothingness and you're almost frightened and crushed under it so what actually crushes you is that if
you ever take on board and grasp the enormity of what the Lord is saying to us and the more we enter
into that and try and take it on board the responsibility is massive so he says the more I draw you to
myself the more I make known to you who I am and what the all wants of you that's when you begin to
feel the weight of this so that's the more you will feel your nothingness okay now there is one of
the big big keys if you're teaching other people about divine will one of the signs that you're
actually making progress in divine will is that you're growing more and more and more in nothingness
if someone still thinks they're important they're not in divine will if someone still thinks that
God and everybody else needs me you're not in divine will you're somewhere else but you're not in
divine will the sign that you are approaching the one who is everything is that it strikes you more
and more and more that I am absolutely nothing and we need to have the Lord give us a revelation
about that because if you are not completely healed of emotional mental problems are struggled from
the past you might interpret nothingness in a negative way I am no use I have no value that's
not at all it's by comparison with who God is and you've heard me say many times that even the solar
system is only a speck of a speck of a speck in the universe so to get the parameters right so
that we are looking at ourselves correctly in relation to God that's where the nothingness comes in
and if you experience the nothingness you know that it is totally liberating totally and completely
liberating I think it's an absolutely divine institution that I'm completely nothing and the
all is prepared to give everything right that's fantastic but the more you go into what I have to
do because the all is spending any time with me is and you become almost frightened he said because
he was telling her that she was third in line that he was the creator his mother brought on
redemption and she was to bring on sanctification and I mean it was just considering the woman was
sitting in a bed as far as everybody else was concerned doing nothing how on earth could she do
this and so the sheer weight of what was being said to her was what was giving her the problem
and so you would want to escape he said from manifesting that is in the writings and even more
from writing on paper that which the all wants to make of this nothing of yours but of course if
we understand absolutely that we are nothing nothing nothing nothing nothing nothing what does it
matter if the all wants to use me as a pencil or a pen he's the one that's important but the
office that was given to Louisa was massive so more so since as much reluctance as you feel I always
when he said I always get what I want in other words she really is surrendered to him so in the
next paragraph the all wants to operate in the nothing and of course the examples are our blessed
mother and Louisa and then it comes to us he wants to operate in us he chooses to do that
it glorifies his greatness this happened also to my celestial mother when she was told I hail you
Mary full of grace you will conceive the son of God and on hearing this she was frightened she
trembled and she said how can this happen but she ended up saying fia biki sakondam bairvam to him
she felt all the weight of the all over her nothing and naturally she was frightened she was
only 14 so when I manifest to you what I want to do with you and you're nothing is frightened
I see the fright of the sovereign queen being repeated and sympathizing with you I lift your
nothing I strengthen it and I enable it to endure everything that God wants okay so the privilege
of being in this nothing place is that he does everything that's the brilliant part of it so he
strengthens us he enables us to endure whatever it is that he's asking he is the one who is doing
all the work where the receptor and the responder therefore don't be concerned about this he said
but rather think of letting the all operate in you so relact and let it happen now he's been telling
her for the 19 volumes let me do let me do because human beings like to have some level of control
so after this she said I was doing my usual acts in the supreme volition embracing everything
and everyone you see this is a universal mission this has nothing to do with me and my growing
in holiness or anything to do with that this is what God wants to do for the human race and I have
the incredible privilege of being part of it so you embrace everything and everyone to be able to
bring to my creator the acts of all as one single act bring it all together now while I was doing
this now I wanted to watch this carefully my sweet Jesus came out from within my interior and embracing
everything together with me he unites himself with me doing what I was doing now the normal thing
is that we fuse ourselves in him and we unite ourselves with his act and we echo what he's doing
this is totally utterly amazing it's the other way around completely amazing and now you're looking
at the humility of God the humility of God is the most astonishing thing of all
then all love Jesus said to Louisa my daughter I love so much the act on in my will that I myself
take on the commitment to keep them in custody I mind them I take care of them he says and I do
it in the unity of my supreme light that means in the heart of the Trinity right there in the center
that's where they're taken care of and when we go to heaven they're all there waiting for us
and I do it in such a way as to render them inseparable from me and from my own acts which
he has just illustrated by actually joining Louisa in what she was doing so in the early volumes
of Louisa's writings we're used to hear that blessed mother and Jesus that they were inseparable
then from about volume 14 or 15 you began to hear that Louisa was the inseparable Louisa
now we come to all of our acts have got to be inseparable from the divine will as well
and that's where we begin to move in towards possession of God it's really astonishing
I think the only way to understand this is to sit with it and ask the Lord to open that's what I do
I just say Lord open my mind open my heart open my spirit so that I can take this in that I can
absorb it and let it happen so if you knew how jealous I am of these acts because they're divine
and they're in the heart of the Trinity how they'd glorify me in a completely divine way
this is it that acts done on a divine level our divine acts and therefore glorify God in a divine
way it can be said that each of these acts it's a new feast that begins both in heaven and on earth
so flowing in my will like a ray of light these acts bring new joys feasts and happiness
wherever my will is that means all the saints in heaven benefit all the souls in purgatory benefit
and all the struggling souls on earth benefit as well why would you worry about people
I think one of the signs as well that you have grasped what divine will is
is that you don't worry about anything the only concern you have is that you are cooperating
as deeply as possible with what God is trying to do through you and with you and in you
and then I get lost and wondered that he would even notice me at all
so both heaven and earth benefit from it these act are the joys the feast and the happiness
that the creature forms in the will of our Creator therefore we are given the privilege
of giving joy to God now when you consider the problems we have on earth and the dreadful problems
that are in the church and the loss of faith and all the rest of it that we see all around us
what an incredible privilege to be able to give joy to God and do you think it's trivial that a
creature can form and bring feast and joy and happiness to her Creator fantastic and then he starts
again and he says look the same happened to my mother as she always operated in the unity of the
light of the supreme will that means totally united to God all her acts in the heart of the Trinity
all of her acts her office of mother her rights of queen remained inseparable from her Creator
that's because she was totally fused all the time and all her acts were at this divine level
so much so that when the divinity unleashes the acts of beatitude to make the whole
of the celestial fatherland happy it unleashes with them all the acts of our celestial mother
you see all her acts are in the divine will they're all inseparable from him and he says that when
he unleashes the glory of the divine acts all her acts are unleashed as well he's going to move on
and show us some responses we need to give to this so all the saints feel invested not only with our
joys and beatitudes but also with the maternal love of their mother with the glory of their queen
and with all of her acts converted into joys for the celestial Jerusalem all the work that she did
for God on earth is translated into joy for everyone in heaven that means that we've just set it up
above that all the acts we do in the divine will are also translated into joy for God and for all
the dwellers of heaven as well every fiber of her maternal heart loves all the children of the
celestial fatherland now the children of the celestial fatherland are the true children of God
mentioned in Romans 819 so her maternal heart loves all the children in the celestial other land
with the love of a mother and she shares her joys of being a mother and her glory of being a queen
with everyone in heaven everybody shares everything with everyone and in the divine will we learn to
share our lives and our acts with everyone as well so on earth watch this now she was the mother of
love and sorrow for her children because on earth you have the cross and you have sorrow and you've
got sufferings and these children cost her so much as much as the life of her son who was God
and by virtue of the unity of the light of the supreme will that is the most blessed trinity
working within her which she possessed because this whole thing in the divine will is moving towards
us actually having the possession of God her acts remained inseparable from ours now that's the way
it was on earth now in heaven she is the mother of love and of joy the sorrow is turned into joy
now when you go back to the prophets like the prophet Isaiah for example I said that those who
are redeemed would have everlasting joy on their faces that's Isaiah 35 around verse 11 so she's
the mother of love and of joy and of glory for all her celestial children so all the sorrow on earth
is turned into joy and all the suffering on earth is turned into glory and that's what St Paul tells
us in Romans I think it is that while we suffer in this life cannot even be compared to the joy
that is going to be revealed to us when we see him so all the saints have greater love more glory
and more joy by virtue of their mother and sovereign queen now we're going to hear in a few minutes
that there are two types of saints in heaven before the divine will the saints belong to the body of
Christ in the divine will they belong to the head okay so whether they belong to the body or the
head your destiny is heaven anyway but what he's saying here is that all of them when they arrive
in heaven they naturally enough are locked into the divine will when they arrive but they receive
more joy and more glory and more blessing and more everything because of our blessed mother
and all her acts and they will share in all the acts of all of us who do divine will acts
therefore Jesus said I love so much the one who lives in my will that I lower myself to her to do
what she does together with her that's where we started two paragraphs ago I will do what she does
and I want to raise her up to the bosom of the eternal one and render her act one with her
creator you can have no greater privilege and so what Jesus is saying he first of all did the
action in paragraph one and now he explains why it is that he will lower himself as a divinity
to come and actually do our acts with us because he wants to take those acts right back into the
heart of the Trinity and those acts as I said will be waiting for us as suns as you and as
full of light and joy and glory okay now in the next paragraph Jesus is going to talk about the
triumph of the divine will in history and no matter what part of history it is it's all one triumph
but when we look at it and we read it in this struggle between God and the human beings in the
Bible for example it doesn't look like triumph but he sees things differently to us and his triumph
comes in different stages and then there will be the final triumph so after this I remained thinking
about the blessed will of God louisa said and many things wandered through my mind which is not
necessary for me to put on paper and my sweet Jesus coming back added my daughter the triumph of my
will is connected with creation and with redemption and it can be called one single triumph since a
woman was the cause of the ruin of man it was a virgin woman after four thousand years letting
my humanity united with the eternal word be born of her that's john one fourteen provided the remedy
for the ruin of fallen man there's a major triumph now the remedy for man is formed it's done redemption
is accomplished you see is my will alone to be left without its full completion while it was the
prime act both in creation and in redemption the prime act is the first act is the very reason
why creation and redemption were carried out so the most important thing is the divine will behind
it all so this is why after two thousand years more and you know with the lord a thousand years
is like a single day we have chosen another virgin as the triumph of the fulfillment of our will
forming its kingdom in your soul that's louisa and making itself known with its knowledge my will
has given you its hand to raise you to living in the unity of its light so that you may form
your life in it and the divine will may form its life in you now there you have it in a nutshell
so the lord wants to raise each one of us up into this divine union with the father the son and the
holy spirit that's living in the unity of the light because god is light so that we can form
our life in the divine will and that the divine will can form its life and kingdom in us but notice
there are two parties that have to cooperate together and work closely together okay and having
formed its dominion in you the divine will forms the connection now in the next little bit i want to
sort of say to you when he's talking about connection tink off either wi-fi that connects the whole
world together well on the internet or tink of electricity and the wires that connect different
part of the house he's talking about connecting one with another and in the divine will he has
connected us with all creatures past present and future animate and in an art okay so and having
formed the dominion in you that's in louisa the divine will forms the connection or the conduit
through which to communicate its dominion over all other souls and just as in descending into the
womb of the immaculate virgin the word did not remain in it for her alone it was for the rest of
us that he came but i formed the connection of the communication of all souls and i gave myself to
all and as a remedy for all now notice the all all all all all as far as god is concerned he has
one family and it's the entire human race past present and future the divisions we make and the
problems we give ourselves are just our problems and when you really get into the divine will he
will let you see everything as he sees it and therefore you will see the human race as one
so everything was for everybody and it is their own choice as to whether they cooperate or not
so the same will happen to you by having formed its kingdom in you my supreme volition forms the
communications to make itself known to souls now one of the major communications here are the 36
volumes the knowledge must get out everything i have told you about the divine will the knowledge
i've given to you the way to live in the divine will the how of living in the divine will my making
known to you what the divine will actually wants and how it yearns for man to return into its arms
and enter once again into its origin of the divine will from which he came these are always a
communication and he insists on us communicating that to other people as well how can they come into
divine will if nobody tells them about it these are always a communication these are all bonds of love
transmission of light a breeze to make them breed the air of the divine will and therefore to disinfect
the air of the human will and that a mighty wind will come to conquer and operate the most rebellious
wells i have to give you that in Hebrew it's absolutely fantastic ruk gadol ruk is wind and gadol
is a mighty wind and it's the description that saint luke gave for pentecost ruk or uac h if you
want to write it down and gad ol phonetics of course it was st luke's definition of pentecost
and so the kingdom of the divine will manifesting fully on the earth actually means the definitive
pentecost the fulfillment of jol chapter three that the holy spirit would fall upon all flesh
big big stuff here so i'll give you acts chapter two verses two to four for the first pentecost
now in the next paragraph jesus speaks about what he was doing in the hidden life in nazareth
and it was all a preparation for the public life and then in the following paragraph he says
to louisa and you're having a hidden life as well here in your bed for the past 40 years and it's all
preparation for the kingdom of the divine will and the lord is doing that with us in a much smaller
way giving us time to sink and time to pray and time to go deeper into things and i think that's
one of the reasons why god has permitted us to be locked up for so long he has given us time to
sink and pray and come close to him so let's start with jesus first and then louisa every added
knowledge i have given you about my will contains a creative power it's god's word and god is the
uncreated word of god and he is the creative power and when his word was given expressed he said let
there be light and there was light when jesus told a child to get up from her bed of death she got up
when he called lassarus out of the tomb lassarus came out of the tomb when he told illness to go
away illness went away nothing can stand before the creative power of god and we need to more and
more deeply get inside of the reality that we're dealing with the creative power of god and allow
him to recreate us so that he can recreate others everything he says is in letting this
knowledge out that's the reason why we have classes why we want to share it with other people
to get other people to come to understand because the power they contain will know how to breach the
way into people's hearts so exposing them to this material is exposing them to literally jesus
speaking to them in their own hearts and calling them and it breaches a way to get them to submit
to the dominion of the divine will but they must actually know the text did the same perhaps not
happen in redemption as long as i remained with my mother in the hidden life and of Nazareth everything
was silent he said although this hiddenness of mine together with the celestial queen served
in an admirable way to form the substance of redemption now what do you mean by the substance
of redemption he was living a life of sacrifice he was living a life of intercession for souls and
he was in contemplation with god he was preparing the the ground work completely and she was working
with them as well so it formed the substance of redemption so that i might announce myself as being
already present now already present is a manual god with us so the people of israel were crying
out for a messiah and the messiah was already there so i could announce myself as being already
present but if jesus simply announced himself as present without actually preparing the way
the people wouldn't have been ready to receive him and it's the same with the divine will all the
work that jesus did with louisa and with the first people who heard this message was all necessary
so that you and i could actually hear it and benefit from it but when did the fruits of redemption
communicate themselves in the midst of the people that's in the public life he said when i went public
when i made myself known when i spoke to them with the power of my creative word and as all i did and
said spread and keeps spreading until now in the midst of the people then did the fruits of redemption
have their effects and still do so the word of god is still spreading around the human race
for all the new generations okay and anybody who comes to it can be transformed by it so the work of
redemption goes on but jesus had to put that word out the apostles had to pick it up they had to send
it on to us so here in the hidden life that louisa has jesus is giving all the knowledge to her
she has to write it down and from there it has got to go out to the whole world
indeed my daughter if no one had known that i had come upon the earth redemption would have
been something dead and without the effects on creatures so knowledge gave life to its fruits
it's getting the knowledge out is extremely important so jesus said louisa it's the same
for you in my will knowledge will give life to the fruits of my will therefore we've got to study the
volumes this is why i wanted to renew what i did in redemption choosing another virgin remaining
hidden with her for 40 years or more segregating her from everybody in a new Nazareth to be free
with her to tell the whole stories the tragedies and the goods contained in the divine will so as to
be able to form the life of my will and use exactly the same pattern and just as i chose saint joseph
watch this now to be together with me and my mother now what was joseph asked to do he was to
be our co-operator he was to be our tutor that's not usually emphasized by teachers and
commentators in the church that joseph was the tutor of jesus we were told mary was and he was
to be the vigilant sentry for me and for the sovereign queen in the same way i have placed near you
vigilant assistance of my priests as co-operators tutors and repositories of the knowledge goods
and tragedies contained in my will now you know that for the first ten volumes at least
luisa was asking jesus take the priest away take the priest away i don't want the priest coming
he had to absolutely insist and it's only now she begins to appreciate why he insisted on the
priests being present that they were like the apostles listening to the teaching of jesus having
to receive it give it to the church and get it out from the church to everybody from the center of
the church to everybody so he continues since my will wants to establish its kingdom in the midst
of all people through you i want to deposit this celestial doctrine in my ministers so through
luisa they're not getting it directly from jesus they're getting it through her as my new apostles
that's the apostles of the divine will so that first i may form with them the link
of connection with my will now it's very interesting that one of her professors of course is canonized
and she saw at least two others in heaven as well and so they were to be the apostles of the divine
will it was through them the first links were made and of course Hannibal de Francea set off
the congregation of the Rogation fathers and sisters and through those congregations the message
spread like welfare and then they were to transmit it into the midst of peoples which i've just
illustrated if it were not so or were not to be so i would not have insisted so much on having
you right nor would i have permitted the daily coming of the priest but i would have left all my
work between me and you i would never get out because luisa wouldn't write it therefore be attentive
and leave me free to do what i want to do okay now he's been telling her that for the whole 19 volumes
now who can say how confused i remained with this teaching of jesus i remained mute from the depths
of my heart i repeated fiat fiat fiat that's what you say fiat miki sacondum verbum to him so we come
to do in the 20th 1926 and we're dealing with that moment that you read about in the 17th hour of the
book of the passion of jesus and some of the words here are identical to what you get in the hours of
the passion after going through most bitter days because of the privation of my sweet jesus i felt
i could take no more i moaned on the repress that crushed my soul and body now since volume 15 anyway
maybe earlier luisa began to realize it was the weight of the world that was pressing on her
it's not just you have the weight of the all but the whole world was depending on her
opening the doors to the divine will to the human race so she feels this
infinite press this divine press which caused her an awful lot of stress and pain and anguish
and i longed from my celestial fatherland which she's no longer asking to go to heaven she realizes
she's a job to do on earth in the early volumes she was forever asking to be released to go to heaven
so i longed from my celestial fatherland in which not even for one instant would i be without the
one who is all my life and my highest and only good so you've read that for 19 volumes that very
same sentence then when i reduce myself to the extremes without jesus don't forget the reason
why this happens is because she's in bed she is un exercised she is not being fed and she's not
even drinking so her dependence on him is physical mental emotional and spiritual that's why if she
goes through a kind of a death and resurrection experience and then she said watch this now this
is very important i felt myself being filled completely with him in such a way that i remained
like a veil covered by him so she's a living host and he's the center and she's the veil and since
i was thinking about the pains of his passion and accompanying him especially in the action which
pilot showed him to the people saying etce homo that's john 19 six my sweet jesus told me
my daughter as pilot said etce homo everyone cried out crucify him crucify him we want him dead
and so did my very celestial father which is explained in the 17th hour of the passion and my
inseparable and pierced mother now why would the celestial father wanted because the blessed
Trinity had chosen that the second person of the blessed Trinity was to redeem the human race
and that was the way it was to be done and why would his mother wanted as well is that she was
the most redeemed person on earth everything was redeemed in her and therefore he died for her first
you have this wonderful exclamation given by st. Paul in Galatians two 21 when he says he loved
me and he died for me and jesus explains that everybody had to cry for his death because he had
to suffer the death of each one of us and so it wasn't just the celestial father and his beloved
mother and not only those who are present but all the absent and all the generations past and future
otherwise they wouldn't be saved there was only one name under heaven by which we could be saved
that's act chapter four and if someone did not say it in words they said it with facts
because there was not a single one who said he wanted me alive and to keep silent
is confirmation of what the others want so what he's saying is that if some people in the crowd
didn't actually shout crucify him but they didn't say don't do it then jesus is saying they did it
this cry of death from all was so very painful for me that's the bleeding of the lamb
i felt as many deaths for as many people as were the people who cried out crucify him
so jesus literally died for each one of us so i'll give you one Corinthians 15 3 as well as Galatians
221 i felt as though drowned with pains they're the pains we should suffer in hell and with death
that is the second death if we were unredeemed people more so since i could see that each death
of mine would not bring life to each one in other words not everybody would be saved
poor judas being the first example and the tea found the cross who absolutely refused
to stop cursing him and called for his help and those who received life because of my death
would not receive all the complete fruit of my passionate death so even the ones who would allow
him to be saviour wouldn't actually accept the fullness of redemption and so they wouldn't allow
the complete transformation of their being they wouldn't allow him to bring them all the way into
union with God so how could he have brought about the kingdom of the divine will if the human race
was merely at this stage he said my sorrow was so great and my moaning humanity was about to succumb
and breathe its last now that's the way louisa is saying she feels when jesus doesn't come but
while i was dying the all-seeingness of the supreme will made present to my dying humanity
all those who would let the eternal volition reign in them with absolute dominion in other words
the blessed trinity allowed jesus in his dying to actually see all who would live in the divine will
and all who would take the complete fruit of my passion and death because to live in the divine
will is to receive the full fruits of the passionate death of jesus he paid for it all
so that was his consolation as he was dying i remember many years ago when i was doing a lot of
reading and studying of the lives and the teachings of the saints that some of them were saying that
yes jesus did have an interior consolation to enable him to die but they weren't actually
able to describe it and here you have it that he was able to see into the future those who would
actually live in the divine will and take all that he had provided for their redemption
so among them was my dear mother as their head she was going to take the most because she's the
greatest saint she took all the deposit of all of my goods and she took all of the fruits contained
in my life passion and death so she's the one who benefits the most not even one breath of mine
did she allow to be lost nor did she fail to keep this precious fruit in her custody
in other words she never sinned she never went out of the divine will and so all the gifts and
graces and fruits of the redemption were completely safe in her you've got that lovely statement in
Luke chapter 2 I think it's verse 54 that she kept all these things in her heart and meditated
around them in her heart and from her they were to be transmitted to the little newborn of my will
that's louisa and to all those to whom the supreme volition would have its life and its kingdom so
the person who benefited the most was blessed mother and then louisa and then us okay so in the
next paragraph Jesus again tells us for the end time that if we really are living in the divine
will that the divine will will empty us of the human will okay when my extinguishing humanity saw
the complete fruit of my passion life passion and death placed in safety that's in his mother
and secured it was able to resume and continue the course of its sorrowful passion in other words
he could pay the price it wasn't wasted so it is my will alone that brings all the fullness of the
goods and the complete fruit contained in creation redemption and sanctification it's only living
in the divine will that can actually give you the full fruit where the divine will reigns our works
are all full of life nothing is halved or incomplete and where the divine will doesn't rain even if
some virtues are present everything is misery everything is incomplete and if they produce any
fruit at all it's on ripen without maturity and if they take the fruits of redemption they take
them with measure and without abundance and therefore they grow weak sick and feverish spiritually
and if they do a little bit of good they do it strained and they feel crushed under the weight of
that little bit of good that they do now notice that everything is heavy with the human will
everything is difficult everything is struggle on the other hand this very Jewish way of thinking
on the one hand and on the other hand on the other hand my will empties the human will now notice the
word empties i want you to watch that now because this should be happening to us and in the void left
from the emptying of the human will the divine will places the divine strength
and it places its life now notice there must be an absolute self emptying there's no way around it
therefore one who lets the divine will reign within herself does good without strain and the life
she contains leads her to operate good with an irresistible strength so my humanity found life
in my passion and death and it found life in those in whom my will would reign so here you have
him seeing the fruits before he actually died therefore creation and redemption will always be
incomplete until my will has its reign in souls so in the next paragraph he comes back to the subject
of our littleness and he says actually your littleness is my triumph you see once the fall took place
satan who is the prince of pride made sure that pride covetousness lost gluttony anger
slowed the whole seven of them were planted in us these terrible roots of sin and when you join
pride and covetousness and lost and greed and a few others when you put them together you
put up a massive block against god inside of you and so for him to reach the point that we're even
willing to be little people let alone arriving at that point it's a complete triumph for him
so i want you to see in the next two paragraph i think it's beautiful he's saying that our descent
into littleness from the pride where we started our descent into littleness is actually a great triumph
for him because each step down into our nothingness is a triumph for him because he can work more and
more and more and more with us and so when we arrive at the void at the real emptiness he has
conquered it's beautiful what he's saying here after this louisa said i was doing my acts in the
supreme volition and my sweet jesus coming out from within my interior which of course means that
the kingdom of god is there at luke 1721 his gaze followed everything that i did and since he saw
that all my acts identified with his sam one three nine says of course that god sees everything
interiorly and exteriorly for all of us since he saw that all my acts identified with his therefore
they were divine in origin they came out of the supreme will they were operated within the light
of the trinity and by virtue of the supreme will they followed the same course as his acts
now here you've got the identification the inseparability and they repeated the same good
and the same glory for our celestial father taken by emphasis of love i think it's about the most
awful translation it means absolute in a in an utterly loving move he gave her a big hug
that's actually what they're trying to say but they say it so awkwardly you wouldn't think
that that was what they were saying he suddenly gave her this big hug and he said my daughter
even though you are little and you're newborn in my will and you live in the kingdom of my will
your littleness is my triumph to kritians 12-9 my power works best in weakness now luisa has been
quite eloquent about her weaknesses all throughout the 19 volumes and he says with my power works
best that way and when i see you operate in the divine will i find myself in the kingdom of my
will like a king who's had fought a long battle six thousand years since his aim was victory
in seeing himself victorious he feels cheered because of this bloody battle and if you read
the old testament it certainly was as you read the history of the church it certainly was a long
bloody battle so from the hardships suffered and from the wounds still impressed on his person
and his triumph is formed as he sees himself surrounded by the souls in the divine will these
are the conquests that he has made the king wants to look at everything his gaze wants to delight
in the kingdom conquered and triumphant his smiles and he makes feast now as each one of us goes
step by step down into our nothingness and therefore he can establish his kingdom more and more securely
within us his kingdom is spreading and spreading and spreading that's his triumph and so he goes on to
in the next paragraph to describe the long years of struggle and the old testament is
absolutely eloquent about it so that's the way i am he said my ideal or my aim in creation was the
kingdom of my will in the soul of the creature my primary purpose was to make of man the image
of the divine trinity now we're told that in genesis one twenty seven and genesis two seven
letters make man in our image but man slipped out of it rather quickly so our primary aim was to make
man in the image of the blessed trinity by virtue of the fulfillment of my will upon him
so we become more and more and more like god in the image of the blessed trinity as the divine will
operates in us but as man withdrew from the divine will i lost my kingdom in him you see
Luke 17 21 says the kingdom of god is within you and so he has to conquer the universe inside of
each one of us individually that's quite some battle so i lost my kingdom in him and for as long
as six thousand years i had to sustain a long struggle what long as it has been i have not
dismissed my ideal and my primary purpose in other words i haven't given up nor will i dismiss it
and if i came in redemption i came to realize my ideal but of course it was only a stepping stone
because the human race had to be cured first and my primary purpose that is the kingdom of my will
in souls this is so true that in order to come i formed my first kingdom of the supreme
volition in the heart of our immaculate mother so you see the kingdom is established inside of
each person one by one and so you could have six people standing together in the kingdom of god
in three of them and the kingdom of the world in three of them everything is what happens inside
of us so i formed my first kingdom of the supreme volition in the heart of the immaculate mother
outside of my kingdom i would never have come upon the earth why Hebrews 12 14 nothing unholy or
unworthy can enter the presence of god have a cook 1 13 god is too holy to look upon sin he couldn't
have entered a sin site then i suffered hardships and pains and i was wounded and killed at last
but the kingdom of my will was not realized but i had laid the foundations that's the
important thing in redemption i made some preparations but the bloody struggle between the human will
and the divine will was yet continued now i'm going to have to hold on to you to finish this
is the longer message so if you read the history of the church and even the the lives of the saints
you'll hear of this terrible struggle within them and i would give you Romans chapter seven
where St Paul says the things i don't want to do i do and the things i do want to do i don't do
this infernal struggle is going on inside of me okay so this was the bloody struggle quite
literally that went on between the human will and the divine now my little daughter he said when i see
you operate in the kingdom of my will and as you operate its kingdom is established more and more
in you now there is an extremely important answer for all your students those of you who are teaching
classes the kingdom of god is established more and more every single time we do an act in the divine
will if you stop doing them there's no development of the kingdom if you keep doing them yes the kingdom
develops inside of you i feel victorious in my long battle and everything around me takes the
attitude of triumph and feast my pains my hardships the wounds smile at me and my very death gives me
back the life of my will in you so when he sees us entering into the divine will and allowing
him to establish his kingdom in us in a very real and substantial and secure way he rejoices and
everything makes sense for him so i feel victorious in creation because we're creatures and in redemption
because he died to redeem us even more they serve to form the long rounds for the newborn of my
kingdom that is us asking blessing on absolutely everything that he has made in creation redemption
and for us a sanctification as well or rapid flights or endless strolls in the kingdom of my will and
so i boast in triumph and delighting i follow with my gaze which of course is sam one three nine again
all the steps and all the acts that's what he does for each one of us he follows every step and
every act that we do so i want to give you proverbs fifteen three there that the lord's providence
covers us all the time with his gaze and now he's going to give an example of an infant and then
he'll give an example of a bird and it might seem strange to you and then he'll go on talking about
us having to put all of this into practice and then he will say but you are the baby and you are the
bird so he's giving the example first normally he gives the teaching and then the example we get
the example first see everyone has their ideal or their aim i don't know why they call it ideal
aim in life and when they realize it only then their content it starts when you're an infant
an infant has what they want as well they want to attach themselves to the breast of the mother
and when he cries and sobs as soon as the mother opens her lap to him the baby stops crying takes on
a smile flinging himself he attaches himself to the breast of his mother and victorious he suckles
and suckles until he's full and while he suckles triumphant he takes his sweet sleep well he says
i'm the same after long crying when i see the lap of a soul who opens the doors to me to give place
to the kingdom of my will my tears stop and flinging myself onto her lap i attach myself to her and
sucking her love and the fruits of the kingdom of my will i take my sweet sleep and i rest victorious
now my memory says that's an explanation of volume four you had louisa having these very
dramatic visions in which either jesus was sucking from her breast or she was sucking from his
and it sounded awfully physical an actual fact it was completely spiritual that we
suck or draw his love and his life and he says that when he finds someone living in the divine will
he comes and draws love and life from us as well does he need it the answer is no so why would he
draw love and life from me it's to give it to all other souls past present and future who need it
desperately and the souls and purgatory as well so then he gives the example of the little bird
even the tiny little bird has its aim the aim is the seed and when it sees it it beats its wings
it runs it hurls itself over the seed victorious it grabs it with its beak and triumphant continues
its flight well he's trying the same i fly and fly i go around and around to form the kingdom of my
will in the soul that she may form from me the seed to nourish me because i use no other food
his food is divine food and so it has to be divine will i use no other food but that which is formed
in my kingdom so that's in the depths of our being in the divine will and when i see this celestial
seed more than a little bird i fly off and take it as my food in volume four particularly that's my
memory anyway it's probably other volumes as well you would have jesus coming to louisa looking for
food that quite literally she was to feed him and she began to understand it's my prayers it's my
sufferings it's my this that the other so for each creature everything is in realizing the aim
or the ideal that one is set for himself this is why when i see you operate in the kingdom of my will
i see that my ideal is being realized and i feel repaid for the work of creation and redemption
and i feel the triumph of my will established in you therefore be attentive and let the victory
of your jesus be permanent okay now we come to us this is a very very important passage now louisa
solves it for us but it may not have resolved itself fully in your life and my life in other words
jesus has spoken to us about the long years of struggle he's had with the human race to try and
get the human will to surrender to him and now he's going to tell us that he has long years of
struggle with you and me to try and get us to surrender our will fully and permanently to him
and still a bloody battle okay and then he'll have his final victory now louisa gives the answer
that we should give and we can give it verbally but it may not have happened in reality fully so
after this my jesus moved in my interior at all tenderness he said my daughter tell me what is your
ideal what's your aim what's your purpose what is it what do you want in other words where are you
going with this stuff like a person could be attending a class could be enjoying the classes
could be enjoying the teacher could be enjoying meeting with others without necessarily making
the journey so louisa said my love jesus my ideal or my aim is to fulfill your will and my only
purpose is to reach the point at which no thought no word no heartbeat and no work of mine would
ever go out of the kingdom of your supreme will now she's very clear even more in the divine will
may they be conceived nourished raised and formed their life that is all my thoughts words heartbeats
acts movement steps everything she wants them conceived nourished raised and formed in the divine
will and if needed also their death though i know that in your will no act dies she says but once it
is born it lives eternally so she wants absolutely everything every thought word action movement step
ambition intention motivation desire the lot everything that makes me me she wants it all in the divine
will so it is the kingdom of your will in my soul my poor soul that i long for and this is my full
complete aim and my primary and ultimate purpose so jesus was all love and he made
feast and he added my daughter your ideal or your aim is the same as mine the two of us have the same
one and therefore our purpose is the same brava brava the little daughter of my will and since your
aim or ideal and mine are the same you two have sustained the battle of long years volume one to
nineteen so please i mean i've heard it on the grapevine that some people are claiming to have
reached a very high state in the divine will i'd love to meet them we have long years of struggle
to actually get our will to actually surrender everything everything everything everything to
make a complete holocaust for the lord it's that holocaust he's looking for
you can say all the acts of consecration you like but if you're not actually surrendering your will
in the everyday events of your life it's not going to work because it's not a devotion
it's not about fancy prayers even if they're the most beautiful prayers it's not about that
it's about letting jesus conquer us completely and totally so that the kingdom of heaven
actually does reign in us okay so you two have sustained the battle of long years
to conquer the kingdom of my will you have to endure pains privations and you have been a prisoner
in your little room you've been bound to your little bed to conquer the kingdom so much wanted
and longed for by me and by you the fact that you actually want the kingdom of god to be fully
established in you doesn't mean it won't be painful doesn't mean there will be no struggle
we've seen louis's struggles all throughout the volumes
it was very honest about them it cost much to both of us it costs not less than everything
for you and me to actually finally surrender the human will to the divine
oh we'll do it in bits and pieces but you know to give it all and complete it's different it cost
much to both of us and now we are both triumphant and conquerors can't you see that jesus is telling
her that the battle is won in her she's already arrived this is only volume 19 we've only started
the second half of these writings so you two are the little queen in the kingdom of my will
and even though little you're always a queen because you are the true daughter of the great
king now roman day 19 says that there will come the true sons of god and you're always a queen is
song of songs chapter six verse nine you and i are both conquerors revelation two and three
therefore as a conqueror of a kingdom so great take possession that's what it's about
the whole thing goes to us having possession of god and god having possession of us that's where
it's going so take possession of all creation take possession of all redemption and take possession
of all heaven everything is yours because your rights of possession extend wherever my will reigns
as whole and prominent all are waiting for you to give you the honors that be fit your victory
louisa has won it's absolutely fantastic and we're only at volume 19 so now he comes back to the
fact that she's a baby and she's a bird you two are the little baby who has so much cried and
longed for her jesus and you see that and all the statements about her very painful privations
you two have cried and longed for your jesus but as soon as you've seen me your tears have stopped
and flinging yourself onto my lap you have attached yourself to my breast and victories you have
suckled my will and my love now there's the answer to volumes one to six what is going on
in these visions she is drawing love and life from him and he is drawing love and life from her as
well that's actually what's going on but if i can give you an image which is not here it's just
come into my mind the true communion between man and woman in marriage is also a drawing of life
and love from one another it's a mutual gift and a mutual receiving and it is love and life that's why
to kill the life that comes out of that communion is terrible you have suckled my will and my love
as though in triumph you have taken rest in my arms and i rocked you so that your sleep might be
longer that's sam one three one and i might enjoy my newborn in my own arms you see sam one three one
my soul is like a weaned child on its mother's lap and that's what he's talking about here
and triumphantly said i extended the kingdom of my will in you now notice extended i grew it
it kept on growing and growing and growing what louisa is capable of here in volume 19
is infinitely greater than what she was capable of in volume four
the kingdom of the divine will has extended in her and also you are the tiny little dove the little
bird that has gone round and round me that's in her rounds and while i spoke to you about my will
manifesting to you the knowledge about it it's goods and it's prejudice and even it's sorrow you
beat your wings and hurling yourself over many seeds i placed before you you grab them with your
beak and triumphant you continued your flight around me and you waited for more seeds of my will
which i would place before you and again grabbing them in your beak you nourished yourself and
victorious continued your flight manifesting the kingdom of my will now manifesting is the writing
but of course she wrote letters and was in contact with human beings as well so my prerogatives are
yours my kingdom and yours are the same we've suffered together it is right that we should
enjoy our conquests i just think it's awfully brilliant that she has arrived in volume 19
so louisa said i remain surprised on hearing this and i thought to myself but is it really
true that in my poor soul there is the kingdom of the supreme will you see this is spiritual and
so you don't feel it in your emotions i at all confused she said and i wrote this only to obey
but as i am writing i think this is lovely as i am writing jesus has surprised me coming out from
my interior and he gave her a big hug okay and then she went on afterwards and she said i continued
writing i think that's absolutely brilliant so let's go to the next paragraph while i was
afraid jesus told my daughter my celestial mother was able to give me to others because she conceived
me within herself now watch this this is terribly important she raised me and she nourished me
no one can give something he does not have if the kingdom of god is not being established in us
we're not able to pass that on to others we can pass on words all right
and if she gave me to other creatures it was because she possessed me there's the possession
of god again now i would never have told you so much about my will had i not wanted to form its
kingdom in you nor would you have loved it so much had it not been yours now he has told her many times
as we've gone through the volumes people really only loved something that they own and here he is
telling her that from many volumes she's had this kingdom but she didn't realize it and he's telling
her the very way you responded to me about it all told me through tears the things that are not
one's own are kept reluctantly and cause bother and wait had you not the springing fount of the
kingdom of my will within you you would not have been able to repeat what i have told you this is
extremely important you have to go deeper and deeper into the divine will to be able to explain it to
other people and the more you go into it the more you can give it if you're only on the surface you
cannot give this to other people had you not had the springing fount of the kingdom of my will within
you you would not have been able to repeat what i've told you nor would you have been able to put
it on paper lacking the possession look how far she had to go you would lack the light
we would say enlightenment and you would lack the love to manifest it so if the sun shines in you
and with its rays it feeds you the words and the knowledge and how it wants to rain it's a sign
that you possess it and therefore your task is to make it known just as the task of the sovereign
queen was to make me known and to give me for the salvation of all there's a good lot of meat in
that and a good lot of instruction for us so thank you for joining me